the counting is underway and the first
results show the no vote with a clear
lead the Greek interior ministry
projected that over sixty percent voted
no yes or no many voted based on their
feeling for Europe as a whole I would
know why because all the years we vote
yes it was awful from my cabin so I vote
no outside and if it's possible to go
outside from euro drachmas go back to
drag musze is it to every people say no
I voted no because Greece doesn't have
to do all these things just to please
the European Union yeah nine takato we
didn't manage cabbage lovers I think
that we have to vote the yes because we
if we want to stay the European uniform
it's it's absolutely necessary nice so
I'm I'm supporting very strongly yes
vote mirrors the early results are good
news for Prime Minister Alexis tsipras
who was gambling the future of his
five-month leftist government on the
vote he says the referendum offers his
people a chance to resist what he called
the blackmail and humiliation imposed on
them by international creditors only
would not know many people can ignore
the will of the government's no one can
ignore the will of the people to live in
self-determination and take their lives
into their own hands nazih see map of us
dakota a nap i deserted area tsipras
told voters that rejecting the creditors
proposals would give him a stronger hand
to negotiate a better deal with the
lenders but the opposition accused the
prime minister of jeopardizing the
country's membership in the eurozone
they say a no victory could drive
Greece's crippled financial system into
insolvency tsipras and his cabinet are
already drawing up a new list of
proposals for the creditors